hey everybody here we are once again
doing another movie review matinee show
like we do it looks like it's okay it's
not that way I can access the comments
you can see the comments of that organ
plays you got three people waiting on us
right there yeah we got some people
watching what time is it so uh hi
everybody it's almost two o'clock I
thought it was like yeah close we're a
little bit early whatever well cuz like
I said it takes a while for everything
to get alright movin so movie that we're
reviewing today this was one because
remember like on Monday or whenever it
was hey everybody hey hey Melanie um
when we were reviewing Moke which I
think we reviewed on Monday I guess um
this was the other movie that we saw the
trailer for like when we were scrolling
through the thing and we're like oh we
got to save that one for Wednesday cuz
that one looks really good - we were
just more in the mood to watch mope on
that particular day because this one was
more like a horror movie and this one
was actually like I was expecting us be
good because the trailer was like you
know pretty cool and looked like you
know right up my alley but it was
actually like much better than I was
expecting
yeah there's an excellent movie I liked
it a lot it's a South African movie yeah
and you do magic I guess you could say
it's about this this guy is white guy he
inherits his dad's farm out the middle
of nowhere in South Africa and he's got
his wife with him and his little adopted
daughter which is his niece nice yeah
and like on their first day there this
kind of old ragged black dude just shows
up cut out of nowhere saying that he
used to work for his dad wondering if he
needed any if he needed a hand yeah he
was kind of like a homeless dude just
wander around out in the bush and told
him no at first but the guy was so good
with this the generator and it's the
equipment he knew the place so well he
went ahead and invited him to stay in
the damn work shed I guess it wasn't a
work shed
yeah it's just like just like a regular
shed yeah on the property minute like a
room yeah you look like an actual little
cabin yeah well all kinds of weird [ __ ]
happens it turns out the students a damn
sorcerer eventually yeah he's a real
good one and he doesn't have a whole lot
of friends because of that and he got in
contact with this demon I don't know you
know I don't really want to spoil the
whole movie but I mean the thing is it's
kind of hard to talk about without kind
of going somewhat into it
yeah now I will say and and I'm pretty
sure that this was spoiled by the
trailer like I said if we didn't say the
movies called the soulcollector although
when it originally came out I think
going on and Matt showing us some
inflation also I wanted to say about Jed
Mouse there says thanks for helping me
through my workday you guys are awesome
thank you very much thanks we're glad
that you guys are hanging out with us on
this Wednesday afternoon yeah but yeah
so this called the soul collector but I
believe when it first came out I don't
know a lot about like the production
history of this or like I'm sure it
premiered at some festival or something
because I think it premiered at a
festival like in 2019 and it was
originally came out under the title
eight a South African horror story yeah
being like the symbol for infinity which
is kind of like a big thing in the movie
yeah now this movie here okay
the quality is outstanding that the the
acting is super good the score is really
good acting is sucking through the roof
I love the gun yeah that please Lazarus
it slays last where Lazarus distant is
the damn sorcerer
his name's Shimano Seb a I don't know if
I'm pronouncing that right I've never
seen him in a movie before but he's
[ __ ] great he should be in more [ __ ]
and what I liked about the movie is that
it when the movie ended I thought that
was it no no no no no they did something
that movies rarely do they continue and
take it to the next level you end up in
the damn spirit world and [ __ ] yeah what
direction I wasn't expecting I get a
good one
yeah anyway yeah it's pretty cool now I
think the guy that directed this his
name is Harold hell sure or whole sure
because I think there's an umlaut which
would be healthier anything um this
might be his first movie from what I
could gather
but I thing that I liked about this was
just something really cool and I think I
this came across like in the trailer too
which is kind of why we wanted to watch
it like there's just something really
cool like about the vibe of it vibe of
it you don't really see one you don't
see a lot of South African horror movies
and - it just came across as like a
really creepy like fairytale esque
kind of yeah but it wasn't vibe to it it
wasn't dream no not like that but like
in the sense that it's kind of like an
old-school like a like a legit like
Alice story yeah you know it's like
black magic and everything and I thought
that was like really cool and it's a
really cool angle it's like so you don't
see like a lot of you know there's a lot
of supernatural horror movies and stuff
you know and this one's structured kind
of like that but you don't see a lot of
them like kind of through this cultural
prism yeah you know what I mean the only
thing that's kind of close to this would
have been Pumpkinhead which is kind of
like a it's a southern so which is kind
of like the American southern illusion
that you're right yeah but I like this
better than Pumpkinhead even though yeah
I think did I like pumpkin head but get
a cool [ __ ] monster but this is kind
of like an African version of pumpkin
head there is a monster in it yeah I
don't want to [ __ ] really spoil it
and it's weird how it's shown and what
it is like I said some of its in the
trailer so I don't know what I'm kind of
scared to go too much because like I
said it sucks because that's right I
really kind of want to talk about it but
it's like I don't want to was got this
thing with him that he has to feed and
he feeds it he feeds it people's souls
yeah raw soul : yeah he draws Souls out
of people's mouths and gives it to this
thing to keep alive and it's it's
[ __ ] true yeah it's like he's pretty
much established the cool thing about
his character because like I said the
setup of it it's set in its just says
somewhere in South Africa in 1977 which
was still apartheid era was it not so
there's like a little burn of that going
on as well I think yeah yeah cuz I think
it was a little [ __ ] the 80s I can't
remember now but I'm pretty sure that
that was still going on I'm in my memory
so I'm pretty sure it was at least seven
till the 80s if not later
so there's a little bit of that it's not
like super heavy-handed or anything it
was just kind of like a background sort
of thing so you get like this like we
said this white family the dad had this
farm and he dies at the beginning now
like I said at the beginning you know
that the main character like this he's
kind of the villain but kind of not
which is kind of like really fascinating
about his character because pretty much
the first scene of the movie they show
him sitting in the room with the dad and
it seems like he's doing something bad
or that he did something bad to the to
the guy so you know that is this the
villain but he doesn't seem like a
villain because he seems like a really
nice man so it's kind of like this
conflicted thing where you're just like
what is this guy's endgame like what is
he doing is he just pretending to be
nice or whatever so the old guy dies and
then you cut to this family you like I
said it's a it's a man and a woman who
are married and then they have their
niece marry who I guess her parents died
did they say how the parents died I
assume it was in some kind of an
accident
yeah they shouted they burned up didn't
know that was that was Lazarus's it was
a sign that's right I don't know I don't
remember if they said like how Mary's
parents died or not I just like I said I
assume it was an accident because
apparently they both died at once but
I'd have to like go back in there like
there was that whole Mothe angle the two
moths and I don't know well the Mafia
the moths represented yells yeah I know
that but he had him or do you just tell
her did you see I don't know I don't
know if those actually were her parents
or if he was just telling her that yeah
it was weird
I mean because I don't know because I
don't know where her parents were when
they died I don't know if they lived
there or you know or what the deal was
with that I mean they could have lived
there and he could have he could have
gotten their souls right you think he
would have fed the souls to the to the
monster though that's true
but yeah so this little girl comes there
and it was interesting because I think
at first like I don't know if I just
wasn't paying attention at the very
beginning or wasn't like couldn't hear
some of the dialogue but we
no for a time like the man and woman
because the little girl called the woman
aunty so but then you were saying wait
or is this couple married because they
don't seem like they don't come ball
they seem like a couple but then the
thing is like as the story went on they
are but as the story went on there's a
reason for that it's just I guess
because I think there was a thing about
him like having a business and it going
bankrupt and then her being infertile
and that being like tension so and then
then them having to like adopt the niece
and her being pissed off about it
because like look it's not my kid and
all that and she kind of seemed like she
resented having to raise someone else's
kid so I think that's why there was like
this disconnect between the two of them
it wasn't just like that they you know
didn't have any chemistry it was just
that they were like had they had a
troubled marriage for all those reasons
you know what I mean what I liked about
this movie I think what made it
different is that it went through a
whole story arc and it ended had this
been an American movie you just would
have ended right there this one kept
going yeah and there was like another
story on the back of it wasn't really a
twist it was just a continuation it
didn't have to continue like that they
could have just entered it but they
chose not to you know what I mean
well I heard the fire scene and what
happened to Lazarus they would have just
ended it that would have sort of been
the end if it was an American right
just think continued on another 15
minutes and I liked that I don't have
that about it and like I said you know
cuz that wasn't the end it being called
originally it being called 8:00 and like
I said eight being the symbol for you
know for infinity and a lot of the
things that Lazarus said and that other
characters said about things being like
a continuous cycle that very much does
bear upon the ending so the ending when
you think about all the stuff that he
said like earlier like very early in the
film about life and death and you know
everything being like continued and
everything it really did make more sense
the way that it ended even though you
could argue well that the ending was
like a sad ending or a bad ending you
know what I mean because but that made
more sense like with how the story was
going raaah but we're reviewing a movie
that people
scene and trying not to spoil it it's
kind of rough at that point I do reckon
you know I do recommend the movie we saw
it on xbox yes soulcollector I think it
only just even though like I said I'm
pretty sure it premiered at somewhere
like last year but I think it only just
came to VOD like this month yeah it
wasn't that expensive actually I think
is in the past couple days yeah it might
have been because I it was just we saw
the trailer on Monday and I didn't
remember seeing you know you was six
hours to that I think it was $6.99 and
HD and I think you can get an SD for a
dollar less that's usually the way they
yell because that's what they when they
start out they always want twenty bucks
for him but then like a few weeks later
it goes down to $6.99 they don't always
though not yes on what it is yeah some
movies that are like more indie will
come out 693 99 but yeah there was like
there's a mope appeared at 399 which is
weird cuz that was [ __ ] great movie a
movie and it got like a lot of buzz when
it came out so I don't like at the fest
festival it was a lower budget movie
you're not talking about a Marvel
[ __ ] you know superhero movie it was
$2.00 yeah yeah I kind of hope that one
does well but yeah this one it's it's um
it's not like a real jump scary kind of
movie it's not like it was just like a
real like old-school like creepy you
know legend kind of thing where it's
just kind of like you know folklore sort
of made into this like creepy you know
it's especially like this the thing with
it with him in the bag and the you know
what I mean like all that imagery
well like super creepy it was African
yeah it had a good African flavor to to
the monster it odd pirate I probably put
it up there with you know like serpent
the rainbow something like they it
reminded me a little bit of that time
you know which is you know Haiti you
know about you know two holes keeping
souls in jars and like doing things yeah
juju and sucking yeah it's like so it
had that type of aspect to it as well
and I also really liked that the main I
guess what you could call the villain of
the piece
who was Lazarus was not he was a villain
in the sense
that he was doing terrible things but he
was also sympathetic and like you could
understand like once you learned his
backstory you could understand like why
he was doing the things that he was
doing it was kind of like the same kind
of thing you know kind of the same
dynamic with like a good vampire story
where the vampire is really just kind of
cursed more than anything else yeah it's
like got a dude they didn't ask for that
right yeah so it's kind of like I mean
you could argue in this one like Lazarus
did kind of ask for it but I don't his
desperate yeah he was desperate and I
don't think he understood maybe the
extent of like what it would entail you
know what I mean and then like at and I
don't really know I don't think they
said how long he'd been doing that I'm
assuming it wasn't that long because I
mean when they showed you know his
backstory to get him into that situation
yeah it didn't he didn't look that
different so I was assuming that it
wasn't that long ago and like all the
people from the village and everything
looked pretty similar yeah they're
talking about Pumpkinhead I probably put
it up there with Pumpkinhead
like imagine imagine if Pumpkinhead was
an African was based on like African
folklore yes yeah in but yeah it's like
this was a drunken head was probably
said this nut pumpkin it was set in the
80s but there isn't a behavior yeah not
really and they were you know
Pumpkinhead they were out in the middle
of nowhere let's think it's Louisiana
with it I think it was and it didn't
have to wait for a while but it or
Oklahoma or something Arkansas I want to
say it was Louisiana but I'm not and you
know didn't matter what year it was
where they were wooden shacks and old
trucks you know that's true I don't
think they had electricity yeah I have
to I'd have to like look I loved the
idea and I feel like they don't make
enough horror movies with these kind of
like based kind of around this folklore
about you know going to like a witch or
a witch doctor in this case a sangomas
they would call it and like either
summoning a demon or you know summoning
some kind of like spirit that'll come
and like take revenge for you and [ __ ]
like that so
you know what I mean I know there's a
kind of a lot like that but not as many
as there probably should be because I
like folkloric based horror movies so I
think that's why I dug this one so much
because it was just kind of like
everything about this was just like
really cool and I knew I was gonna like
it
like with like in the first scene
because the the first scene was like
really good the cinematography is
gorgeous you know the score is awesome I
really really liked the score a lot I
mean both of us like commented on it
like it was top notch flick it wasn't it
didn't have a little budget filler I
mean acting was great I loved the
interaction between Lazarus's character
and the little girl who's played by her
name's Kato Luna I think you know the
two of their their interactions was
great and like I said that's what was so
cool about this story is that even
though he was like the bad guy he didn't
seem like a bad guy like he seemed like
a really sweet dude and then like the
more you learned about it's like there
was this really complex character and a
really complex relationship that he
developed with this little kid yeah you
can check the trailer there's a trailer
on Xbox it's probably one on youtube
also yeah cuz like I said you saw the
trailer and we were like okay yeah it's
like yeah that looks cool yeah well the
movies even cooler than the trailer so
if you like the trailer you'd like it's
funny cuz I was watching I was watching
another review of it too it's not a huge
amount of reviews of this movie cuz I
guess cuz it hasn't been out on VOD that
long but when I saw the guy was like
he's like he saw the trailer like a
while back and it didn't really make
much of an impression but then like when
he watched the movie he was like oh man
the movie was like so much better than
the trailer like led me to believe or
it's like you know what I mean cuz the
trailer hadn't really like grabbed him
but this I think that the trailer did a
good job of like giving you the vibe of
what the movie was gonna be like cuz as
soon as we saw the trailer was like oh
that looks pretty cool we should like we
should see that and it definitely does I
mean the movie is like way better than
the trailer made it seem but I thought
the trailer was actually pretty cool it
made me want to see it yeah and like I
said the imagery I just loved the
imagery of like him and the bag and you
know just this whole creepy and and I
love this [ __ ] like I said I don't want
I don't want to like ruin the end but
the spirit world [ __ ] at that I love
that they added that because I
was not expecting [ __ ] to go in that
direction I wasn't expecting the movie
to end the way it ended it's funny
because a lot of people in the comment
section of that one were just like they
wanted the ending explained so we had to
explain that that's what I mean it's
like well I can see how if you weren't
really like paying it's because you kind
of had to pay attention because a lot of
the [ __ ] that happened related back to
stuff that the characters had said
earlier I pretty much everybody got what
they wanted no girl kinda yeah
although that's the thing though it's
like did the little girl get what she
wanted I don't know because we're
leaving them swimming there's no that's
true but yes if you like like kind of
old-fashioned what folkloric type of
horror it's not like you know super
jumps Gary it's not like action-packed
or anything like that it's kind of like
it's more like a supernatural drama like
with horror elements so but if that
sounds like something you would like
like I said it's a it's a beautiful
looking movie you know the sound design
is really cool the characters are really
cool like the acting is really really
good in it and all this other kind of
stuff I want to say too that um one of
the things too we were commenting on was
that the wife who was it the character
the wife whose name was Sarah in the
movie I can't member the actresses name
but she was kind of like an interesting
character because she's come across as
like this bitter you know resentful
woman I mean understandably so I guess
you can see where she's coming from but
we were also kind of laughing because
they did that whole trope where she
really did not want Lazarus they're like
working at the farm yeah and the husband
was just totally like dismissing like
every single one of her concerns even
you know in a lot of ways she saw the
demon she was she saw the demon like we
always make we watch like a holiday and
stuff is like you're just a woman Union
women dumb women don't know it we don't
know how reality works our perception
they don't know it's incorrect women
don't know when someone's choking them
in the band
let me don't know when they see a mosque
you're just imagine beyond your peers
yeah no [ __ ] be crazy it's just so
funny the [ __ ] because it's like
every time it comes at a movie I'm Jenny
told me something strangle her in the
damn bathtub I'm like we're trying to
figure it out because she saw a monster
because we're yeah it's like because you
know I wouldn't make something like that
up yeah you know I think most guys of
course no I would hope so you'd have to
have a history of crazy
OCN [ __ ] of seeing [ __ ] which I've done
right so I mean now I will say that when
we were having the poltergeist activity
yeah at this at the house yeah you know
however long ago was a year or two ago
and when I said that I I woke up in the
middle and heard the doorbell yeah you
initially did not believe me yeah
although I told you I would have thought
it was a dream too if I didn't hear it
again right like a second I thought and
I thought you had maybe dreamt it well I
see that's what I thought like I didn't
think I had because I was pretty sure I
was awake so I was just laying there I'm
like okay now did I really just hear the
doorbell at 3:30 in the morning or 4:00
in the morning or whatever it was or was
I just dreaming it so that I'm laying
there and then I know I was awake and
then I heard it again that's when I
really hadn't kicked off in that episode
yet the damn little horse statues didn't
fly off the [ __ ] that's a trail and
some of that other stuff didn't hadn't
happened it hadn't happened yet so it
was kind of like when it was it takes
months for me for me to ramp it up to
get it rolling and then once it really
started rolling when it threw the damn
TV remote in front of everybody that was
it well you can really deny it then deny
then but that was it because everybody
thought it it didn't come back to it
stopped yeah it hasn't had anything I
think the last thing that happened was
like the TV came on and that was like
yeah the TV hasn't been coming on that
was a long time long time ago that was
probably there was two different TVs at
what yeah so it wasn't like just one TV
yeah but the the one that was on a
haunting or maybe it was paranormal
witness I can't remember the one that
pissed me off the most and I think I
even wrote about
that's my blog was there was one where
the woman said that she heard someone
walking around up in the attic she
didn't see was a ghost she don't think
it was a go she thought it was a person
as you would she calls the husband at
work and says hey I hear somebody
walking around into the attic and then
he told her he was she was just
imagining it yeah I'm like I didn't say
it was a ghost I said I heard footsteps
of this like there's a [ __ ] up
there I'm not going up there
[ __ ] that I told you I was like if I
called you and told you I hear somebody
walking around the attic you would come
right home because there's probably a
person I know it's funny when I first
saw that happening when I was a kid it
was with red and Louis it had a lot more
impact on you when you were younger yeah
especially when there was more of it
going on when I was older seeing it
again after so many years it wasn't
quite as impressive as it was I mean it
did more impressive stuff back then but
I'm just like uh yeah okay there goes
yes I got an even get [ __ ] scared you
know man they didn't even upset me I was
just like yeah that's bad
well yeah but because at this point like
ya know probably where it was coming
although it freaked out it freaked out
Jan Demetri well yeah I could see there
then jen-jen went [ __ ] pale yeah I
know there are either oh yeah somebody
recommended um another movie called dust
devil which is another South African
movie I've actually I've heard of that
I've heard of that I don't think I've
seen it but I probably should see that
as well but yeah like I said not a lot
of the South African horror movies out
there but this one was actually a really
good one and like I said I'm kind of
hoping that we see this actor this main
actor linked in some other [ __ ] because
he's [ __ ] great at this yeah I mean
he for me it's like it was a cool movie
like anyway but he just like made the
whole baby like his character was so
[ __ ] cold he would have made a really
good Chief of Police and a remake of
[ __ ] that serpent the rainbow they
remade that he could play I'm sure
they'll get around to it yeah they
should remake any of those [ __ ]
movies though remakes they need to stop
that [ __ ]
yeah well yeah like I said this yeah
what are you gonna do can't stop them
it's like I'm een think about it up they
[ __ ] up okay think about it is that I
mean they wouldn't make them if people
didn't go see them so it's like if you
don't want them to make them then I
think there was another error though IRA
I don't think Hollywood is gonna [ __ ]
survive this not well it was like that
about horror movies too is that I think
that the remake train that kind of
cycled through the 90s in the early
2000s and I think everyone just kind of
got sick of it yeah
so yes she still see remakes nowadays
but not as many because it was a time in
like the 90s in the early 2000 so they
were just like everything was a [ __ ]
remake yeah or like a sequel to like an
old movie or anything like that so I do
feel like in the last 5-10 years we've
seen a lot more original horror movies
you know what I mean so I think that's
like I think design if you ask me these
small movies that we're seeing these
little movies are better than this the
big Hollywood ones well yeah like and
and like we said because it's usually
it's a smaller crew it's usually like
one or two like a small group of people
whose vision you know and to make an
independent movie you really have to
like wanna make an independent movie
because it's like you know you don't
have billions of dollars at your
disposal you don't have like all this
you know that it's not going to get like
massive distribution it's not gonna get
this done the other thing and it's like
it's basically gonna be word-of-mouth so
you gotta kind of want it yeah you know
what I mean and um so in a way like I
said not all of them are good you know
there's there some that are kind of
crappy but it's like we the ones that
we've seen lately like I've seen some
like pretty good [ __ ] horror movies
better than once we saw in the theater
and look at the kind of ones we saw they
feel like the turning and stuff like
that which was kind of terrible what
yeah I remember that one which one was
that
it was the one that was based on turn of
the screw hey you know what it's like I
would have liked that movie a lot better
if they hadn't ended it the way they
ended it like then it would have just
been like a decent movie but I mean even
stuff like you know curse of La Llorona
and stuff like that which is it wasn't
terrible it just wasn't that was a
little more memorable than the turning
though yeah you know I mean it was just
for a lie I just feel like in the wake
of you know whenever the conjuring came
out like 2006 or 2008 or whatever
that I feel like that that became like a
formula like the James Wan formula and
it's like those movies they're perfectly
watchable but you don't I don't even
remember like what's that 18 months and
[ __ ] AMC there very few of those
movies are memorable to me yeah I mean
we did see some good ones and they did
place like some into some indie ones
that were good but yeah but those that
most of them were just like okay yeah
like they were really memorable they
were fun when you watch them but yeah
like a few months later I couldn't even
remember yeah you know which like I said
what are you gonna do I remember venom
yeah that was pretty good yeah that like
that um sonic I remembered that one that
might have been the last one we saw
before the theaters closed yeah I don't
know maybe we saw one more after that I
remember that being like among the last
one I barely remember the Star Wars
movies now yeah well I've never seen
them I don't remember much about them
it's like I tend to remember I don't
know I guess I remember the horror
movies better just because I'm into them
I don't remember any of the damn
superhero movies Marvel superhero movies
I couldn't tell you I remember parts of
endgame I could remit I can remember
parts of [ __ ] Aquaman I can remember
pretty much everything as Shazam well we
shall we saw Shazam twice yeah I like
Shazam I did too yeah that was funny I
can remember the lighthouse I loved them
because those [ __ ] bizarre that's why
but like I said if you're gonna make
something make it [ __ ] weird man
people will remember it more than if you
just make than if you just make some
like knockoff like horror movie that's
just kind of like fun while you watch it
but then like a week later you're like
did we see that somebody said yeah
somebody was talking about sometime in
the 80s the big bands had that boycott
yeah cuz I remember that ain't gonna
play Sun city that came wouldn't I come
out 85 86 something like that that's why
I was remembered I said so that so 1977
South Africa that was still very much
apartheid era they don't really go like
I said they don't really go into it a
lot and the thing but there is I guess
there's like that underlying like way in
the background like that
between you know the white family and
the you know the black villagers and
that kind of thing but like I said it's
not real in the forefront it's mostly
just about it's more about human and his
demon I think the demons name is a Thule
was that what he called it
I think it was Julie or something like
liya yeah it was like some demon that
you you thought the villagers were mad
at him because you know I mean him being
white he thought that they thought he
was trying to take over the damn country
yeah but that's not what why the
villagers were mad at him they were mad
at him because they were associating him
with a damn demon well ya know about the
demon you'll see yeah that's what I mean
it's a because that's why last verse was
a complicated character because he was
speaking you know obviously the white
dude couldn't really speak a lot of I
think it's schoesser or whatever that
languages I don't know what language but
he could speak a little bit of it we
couldn't speak of enough of it to know
like exactly what all they were saying
so him and so Lazarus and the villagers
are like fighting and Lazarus tells the
white guy oh well I don't know why
they're mad it was just something to do
with your dad or something like that but
that was not to go but that's not what
he couldn't really like say the guy that
because he wanted to like hang around
the house for his own reasons but yeah
this is actually a pretty cool [ __ ]
movie like I said if you really like
folklore horror you know and things of
that nature I think you'll really dig it
so you know it's just really creepy
imagery not like super super scary it's
more like a drama like but it does have
like horror elements it's kind of like a
demonic kind of thing going on but yeah
check it out I'm sure you can probably
run it on YouTube we run around xbox
like I said so tech manga badge it says
a good thing I don't remember Star Wars
movies yes they're asking if we're gonna
watch the new unsolved mysteries what
platforms that on oh you know what I
don't know yeah I just realized that
that to be had like almost all of the
old unsolved mysteries because I was
excited about that did you guys know I
just found on to be a toll other Gordon
Ramsay series that I didn't [ __ ] know
about three seasons of the [ __ ] yeah
when does the guy ever sleep
he has like 40 million shows yeah they
got him they're gonna
and have a [ __ ] Gordon Ramsay Channel
they probably already do like on Pluto
TV er so we're just all just just good I
mean holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
like he and he just started that new
show on that geo uncharted which we've
been watching we like we watched the
Louisiana one last night because we
DVR'd it yeah but he has I was on to be
and I just happened to see because I
watched you know old Kitchen Nightmares
on there and so they recommended to me
he had a show called what is it called
24 hours to hell and back or something
like that it's basically like Kitchen
Nightmares but speed it up like instead
of him being at the restaurant for a
week he only has 24 hours so like get
their [ __ ] together um you know he has
like a big [ __ ] semi with the whole
kitchen in there and all this other kind
of crap and so there's three seasons of
this show and I never even heard of it I
don't understand like how this guy has
time to make all these [ __ ] shows
it's still not as good as the damn
British ones though honestly that's the
gold standard yeah I liked the British
Kitchen Nightmares better because one
they were longer because they don't have
as many ad breaks weirder weirder people
yeah like eccentric kind of people um
also two guys the guy with the plates
yeah we'd watch that the real gravy but
also also because Gordon came across as
much more chill and like much more
understanding they go a lot more into a
you know what I mean that the American
one is good but it's mostly fast paced
too quick edited it's just like they
just want everybody yelling it's real
[ __ ] official which you know to an
extent is funny because I enjoy watching
Gordon yell at people but especially
people that are being at the furnish
ones get into who the damn restaurants
owner
owners are much more like in depth and
like I said they're less concerned with
like everyone's reaching at each other
but this is why I like a lot of people
that like cooking shows that's why like
the the Great British Bake Off shows and
stuff like that has such like a huge
American fan base it's just because it's
so civilized it's like you know what I
mean these people are competing but it's
like they're not [ __ ] they're not
[ __ ] they're not like they're just
trying to bake the best thing they can
bake and it's just like it's just so
wholesome and I can see why
people are way into that because it's
very relaxing you know watching like
shows where everyone's just screaming at
each other it's just like really
stressful saying that unsolved mysteries
will be on Netflix okay no one else is
gonna be on Netflix is that the new
seasons of Cobra Cobra Kai because I
just found out I don't know when the
third see but I just found out like from
Austin Burks channel his movie review
channel which is really good if you
haven't heard of it he just said that
there was an article Netflix got the
rights to the first two seasons and
they're gonna be showing like premiering
the third season because I think what
YouTube is doing they want to do more
because you know they have YouTube read
or YouTube premium or whatever it is
they want to get more into like doing
more reality based series rather than
scripted fictional series so the you
know the the popular series that YouTube
had which Cobra Kai was one of the most
popular they're kind of you know selling
those to other platforms just because
they want to go more into like doing you
know more reality TV type series rather
than life you can't come foo didn't you
guys see art of self-defense like I uh
he keeps some people said they're gonna
see it but then never get around to
seeing it but that's a good one too
Cobra Kai and art of self-defense
they're both pretty good I really really
liked Cobra Kai I didn't expect to
because it's like I you know I like
everybody else that grew up in the 80s I
liked the first Karate Kid movie um it
wasn't my favorite you know but I can
understand like the nostalgia of and
everything it's kind of cheesy but the
show is really really good like I got
way more into it than I expected to and
I love that they got like all the
original actors back yeah and like it's
just like a continuation and they left
it on a [ __ ] on a hell of a [ __ ]
cliffhanger at the end of season two so
I gotta see it again I'm kind of like
yeah so I don't know when Netflix is
gonna transfer the first and second
series over I'm assuming that they're
gonna maybe put it all at once or maybe
they'll put one into up like right
before the third one because I heard
they were working on the third season
and I'm sure it was probably done
I'm pretty sure they were gonna premiere
it that sometime this year so maybe
it'll be in a couple of months that'd be
cool I'm excited about that yeah yeah
yeah well you done talking find a
dentist yeah we better sit cuz I hear
the yard lawnmower achieveable like we
covered what we had to cover yeah so
definitely check this movie out like I
said I don't know every platform I've
seen it's under the sole collector but
it's also called eight a south african
horror story so if that sounds like
something you'd be into then check it
out and we will probably do another live
stream will either live stream the
episode we haven't decided yet in which
case we might do it Friday that or
Saturday night or if we don't then we'll
do another live stream on Saturday
probably movie review or a side tracks
so we'll see you guys again then